paper has a surface had
touched sound hardness a color a
reflection noise and paper is a
storage medium that has survived for thousands of years
without having to save it every few
years
i am a paper maker that means i
create paper by hand my customers
include restorers artists printers
bookbinders  designers architects
photographers and of course that goes on and
[music]
i wanted to do something independently and
i wanted to
be able to influence the whole process, not just being a cog in the machine
but the engine of everything
[music]
[music] the
raw materials for making paper are
classic rags flax hemp
cotton co even with sumatra as
japanese fibers
[music]
i can use old paper pages such
as maps banknotes sheet music
then i can add additives to
calcium carbonate and the
aging resistance to have conductive
medium neutral for the describes
ability pigments to become the papers
1 and so  further and  nd immediately
[music]
i always say paper has character
and you can tell that from a product whether there
is something else that resonates identity documents
in judgments in court papers
paper can make the difference between life and
death paper becomes a carrier of
emotions i think a love letter
[music]
the paper stomach is something holistic
as well as every craft and is beautiful when
the whole thing starts to flow then
you lose yourself in it and can create one
sheet after the other of
course requires the raw material the
recipe the creation everything is right
everything fits and then that's it  great
[music]
the paper maker as a craft it was
removed from the craft roll in the 1950s
because there is de facto
no one left who makes
the haptically quite emotional paper
which we also need in everyday life there
will be an upswing because the
feeling and the desire for  precisely these
qualities will grow again and
demand
[music]